okay so yesterday I did a story about
how YouTube is increasingly destroying
independent news and politics channels
and I explained to you that YouTube is
increasingly prioritizing basically just
what makes the money by keeping
advertisers happy and since September
that has not been independent content
like ours it's been instead this legacy
corporate content and I went through
yesterday in much more detail than I
will do today how our portion of videos
that come from what is called the
suggested video feed on YouTube it's an
algorithm that says oh you watched this
piece of video here's other stuff you
might like we used to get 1/3 of our
views from that suggested video
algorithm that has fallen basically by
50% to under 17% so far in June this may
be it seems like a lot maybe it doesn't
but as I said yesterday this is about
half of what we were once getting from
this algorithm and this decline started
right after YouTube announced that in an
effort to crack down on fake news which
may well be a good-faith effort they are
going to back what they consider
authoritative sources and that has
coincided coincidence right with the
decline from 33% of our views coming
from the suggested view of sources to
under 17 percent and this is a massive
blow to our revenue because it
represents a lot of views I mentioned
yesterday and I'm just getting you up to
speed before I give you the new info
about how this is much worse than even I
thought in December we got three and a
half million views just from the
suggested video feed in June we will be
lucky to get a million and a half views
that's a 2 million view shortfall which
is a huge revenue shortfall very very
big I can't tell you how much revenue
that is but if you google youtube CPMs
you could probably calculate it for
yourselves and I received a flood of
emails yesterday telling me just how bad
it is and it's actually even worse than
I thought I want to remind you Alexander
wrote to me last week or the week before
and he told me something that's really
odd which was that he had never watched
anything by Joe Rogan on YouTube before
and then I was on Joe Rogan's program on
June 5th and Alexander watched one video
on Joe Rogan's channel my interview with
Joe and the next day every single
recommended video was a Joe Rogan video
despite Alexander having watched my
content on YouTube for years and having
been previously recommended my content
on YouTube I now have even more data
points and it's really bad a lot of
people wrote to me with basically some
version of this email that Lisa wrote to
me Lisa wrote to me yesterday and said
hey David just listen to the podcast
where you spoke about the new algorithm
for YouTube I noticed last week that you
were no longer on my home page of
YouTube and I had to search for you I
have a subscription so you did turn up
on the subscription page I've also
noticed that the majority report
Kyle kolinsky and other shows i watch
are no longer on my homepage despite me
having subscriptions for a long time my
homepage is now filled with many things
I don't watch or subscribe to mainly
balanced between parakeets I don't even
know what that is and cardi B I'm so
sorry that this is affecting your show
financially I love your show keep up the
good work
sadly dozens dozens of emails like this
and I as I've said before we know what
the solution is here we've got to
disconnect the programming from being
dependent on ad revenue that that's the
solution I said before I estimate under
1% of my audience funds the show
directly through membership if we can
get from under 1% to 2%
we're in fantastic shape if we can get
to 3% of our audience
supporting us directly we have no more
problems period I mean that's the we're
talking about such small percentages
that going from point 8 percent to 2
percent or 0.8 percent to 3 percent is a
game-changer so I believe this has to be
a wake
call it doesn't have to be this show
okay what I'm telling you is if there
are programs that you like that you want
to see remain independent that you want
to see producing the content they
believe should be produced not what is
going to be monetized by YouTube or
other arbitrary algorithms we need to
support those shows directly if we can
afford to do so with my program the way
to do that is that join pakman.com okay
we have normal prices that I believe are
very reasonable with a pay what you can
afford model starting at $6 a month or
$60.00 per year however I understand
that's a lot of money for many people in
the audience and that's okay we have
discounts available I mean it's just
take the discount if you want it if you
apply the coupon code this is 2020 when
you sign up any membership is reduced by
40% okay I'm going to say something even
further today there is an old coupon
code which we very briefly promoted
which we haven't been promoting but
because the situation is just so
important right now I'm going to give it
out today if you want a 50% discount
okay which will get you down to $3 a
month or $30 a year 30 dollars a year is
like 280 a month okay the coupon code
half 19h a lf1
50% we're not talking about a lot of
money but this is the way that we fix
this problem it's it's the way it's the
most direct way and that's why I'm
asking for your support please share
this video using the share button on
YouTube because it's really important to
get news of what's going on to as many
people as possible and yes I know people
are saying hey David did you hear about
X youtuber who's seeing the same thing
who's on the right maybe did you hear
about X youtuber on the Y youtuber on
the Left who's seeing the same thing yes
I'm in touch with a lot of those folks
and we are talking about this a lot
there's no question about it